today we have a very special event
i think this is probably the first time
in the history of the yale council of
southeast asian studies brown bag series
that we have undergraduate speakers
in fact we rarely have graduate student
speakers
but i was so inspired when i heard about
the work that is going on by these
students at the fulbright university of
vietnam in collaboration with colleagues
in myanmar and other organizations
across southeast asia
that it really struck a chord with me
about the importance of you know
inter-asian student solidarity
especially in these times it's something
we often talk about as scholars about
the importance of inter-asian research
right um but in a moment of decolonizing
the academy rethinking southeast asian
studies to see students from vietnam who
are taking an interest in myanmar
to me is a signal of the important
directions that scholarship and activism
and thinking and work needs to be going
in the future so i was really excited to
be able to find a slot in our brown bag
to afford the possibility for today's
event
the event will be inspired by a zine on
life in poscu myanmar that
funan and tamwin have been working on
with other collaborators at fulbright
university and with a collaborator in
myanmar um
and uh they'll be talking about that
today but let me just say a few words
about who they are so fujang nguyen is a
history sophomore at fulbright
university in vietnam
whose current interest is in human
rights in southeast asia
is a poet art writer apprentice curator
based in ho chi minh city his practice
merges creative writing critical
theories and art history to investigate
vietnamese and southeast asian modern
and contemporary cultural spectacles in
light of neoliberalism and globalization
they're going to talk for about 20
minutes about their zine project then
after that we will also be joined by
laura siegel who is a journalist and
founder of visual rebellion a grassroots
movement of creators for creators and
they they state on their website that
they believe that photography film and
art have the power to create change for
the better they are dedicated to helping
burmese creatives by providing a
platform for their work in opposition to
the military junta extremely timely and
important work so i'm really excited to
have lord joining us here as well
if internet conditions allow we will
also have
a guest who will be going by the name of
marla may
hopefully joining when the internet
allows from myanmar
in joining in on the conversation um so
the structure of our event will
basically be for the first 20 minutes or
so we'll hear about the zine then we'll
hear a little bit about visual rebellion
and then we'll quickly turn it after
about half an hour total to an open q a
discussion and we really hope that that
will be a dynamic conversation that
brings in all kinds of voices during the
conversation
so without further ado let me turn it
over to fulham and bum
thank you for the
amazing
uh introduction
um it doesn't get changed
yeah let me handle the introduction so
hello everyone i'm tamwin and thank you
for the very kind and warm introduction
from eric's and
uh the lunch bag series in general and
thank you everyone for taking your time
to be here with us today
so
let's get straight to the point uh adam
fluent has been working for a
consecutive
period of four months since september uh
i think it's september october of 2021.
as soon as we know and
understand a little bit more about
what's happening in myanmar after the
coup d'etat took over
the government in february 2021
and we felt like there's an urgent need
for to do something that makes this
specific issue visible to the
international community
so
yeah let me just quickly share my screen
right now
okay you can start talking about the
project
so uh thank you thumb so
our project is an independent project
started out as a very
personal project to both me and them
because we feel very strongly about what
is happening in myanmar and
through our personal encounters with
the people who
work
on myanmar and
who is currently living in myanmar
we decided to started this project and
our project is a non-profit independent
and overarching project that highlights
the extreme violence in myanmar which
has not been fully covered by me
international media
um
can you go to that next like this
so uh for today uh after the
introduction we will talk about uh why
why we started the zine why it is a zine
and
what are the contents that we will walk
you through the content
in the scene and we will share more
about the insight into like the process
of making the scene conducting the
interviews and uh
even the translation as well as the
designing
process of the theme
after that we will have a small
discussion which i hope to be uh i would
i i really look forward to uh to have
with the youth from
um
southeast asia uh
like um visual rebellions and
uh
uh and students from southeast asia
movement from yeah
um
and lastly we will talk we'll
spend five minutes to send out
appreciation to the people
uh who have helped us with uh the
production of the zine as well as who
have helped us to promote the scene as
well
thank you
so for
uh as i've uh shared a bit before uh the
reason why we started this project is
because we
felt intrigued by the recent youth
resistance campaigns in myanmar since
the february coup and we are just a
group of undergraduates and artists
with support from
the students from yangon university
and
we decided to initiate a
multi-multimedia
project that centers around a hybrid
artistic non-scholarly zine publication
this project is meant to direct
attention to the current political
turmoil across
myanmar with the southeast asia at the
target in the audience
and
we
that said we
intend to
collect stories and perspectives from
people of myanmar who are living amidst
escalating violence as well as uh
we want to include uh international and
regional stances in responses to the
humanitarian crisis as well if we
uh have uh we have access to the
resources and all of these will be
communicated through a multimedia
project consisting of a series of events
and activities centered around the zinc
publication
uh so uh we have received a lot of
support uh from our
uh organizations from fulbright and as
well as well as from
uh
students from university of yangon
and we believe that in the possibility
in the possibility and long-term impact
of this project as to surface
and highlight the
voices of the people
uh living in
in fosuku myanmar so from fulbright we
have fulbright historical society an
undergraduate community started in
fulbright aiming to promote the history
discipline and his scholarship
um
historical society also provides history
enthusiasts with sufficient support to
nurture their interests and ability to
thrive in both an academic and
professional setting
and we have fulbright art lab a
student-run organization based in
fulbright university vietnam founded in
2018 and our life has coordinated
numerous events and programs such as
film screening panel discussions
exhibitions aiming to create a
connection between art laborers and
communities in vietnam
and we received a lot of support from
interim university council university of
yangon
and iuc iucui is recognized as the legal
administrator of u of university of
yangon by national university
national uni unity government and they
are working accordingly with the energy
ministry of education and also
independently
uh
iuc ucuy has many working processes and
has different
branches one of them is international
cooperation team in which we they try to
connect with overseas universities to
support our their democratic movements
to fundraise and
to
raise awareness about not accepting
non-city and military supporters and the
moment that um
i talked with
my friends from yangon university about
the project uh she immediately
communicated back with the
university council who
who includes uh
faculty staffs and also students from
the university and we received full
support from
iuc ui so a lot of appreciation to
iucui
for helping us with the z
so
all of the
intellectual uh properties produced in
the zinc publication as well as uh
in our project will be
used to raise funds for the for the idps
in
in myanmar and
we have listed uh
we will
um
all donations sent to my paypal account
will be
distributed equally to four
organizations uh listed below
the for the qin
uh state it will be the 10th placement
of fair committees
focusing is the catching relief fund
karen is the doc kalu network and for
currently is the currently guys and
we are waiting for a an official issue
from a bilingual issue from
uh uni uc ui to
um
creative uh to to
to to confirm my
reliability in distributing the funds
sent to my
via my paypal account to these uh
organizations
and here is our
yeah okay
so this is here is the interface of
our website and through this website and
you can see there's like a tiny qr code
on the right side of it you'll be able
to access our website which also houses
uh our zinc publications and we'll talk
about the simplification in a few
minutes
so uh let's talk a little bit about our
own you know like personal encounters
with uh like our very first knowledge of
myanmar and what's happening in the
country
uh
in 2021 i participated in an art writing
symposium that contains a lot of like
curators and art laborers and artists
across southeast asia and and we got
together in this specific program
called term and condition
uh operating and publishing in central
asia organized by a statistic now and uh
uh london school of dr
uh under uh the organization of after
all
so
in this very specific program we talk a
lot about you know like the the state of
cultural production
in contemporary certification as well a
lot of you know the history that
underlined this very
you know process of development
and as i had a talk with a specific
this very specific like bernie's uh
scholar who just got back
from getting her degree in the u.s
she got back right back to me and i
started working there as a teacher and
also in parallel with raising funds for
uh the the the resistance which is
something very powerful that i have not
known before because a lot of you know
like
a lot of the people who joined the
revolution are actually people at my age
and i can just not
face them how
that very audacity and you know a belief
in something that is judicious for
by a collective
you know democracy
would be that powerful to mobilize such
a massive you know number of people and
especially against those of people at my
age the youngsters are putting
themselves out there and
facing the risks
and seeing the brutality
you know committed on a daily basis
so i i decided that's the moment for me
to get to
know
a lot more about what's happening in
myanmar and most of my information comes
from
instagram because we are agency people
right so we do a lot of instagrams and
it's very interesting to see that a lot
of these reports from you know
independent journalists often
come from instagram accounts that are
you know often private so you can see
the contents with the censorship
and those become you know like my main
sources of information
to keep me updated about the situation
and like which regions of nero is
turning into a war zone
and and and stuff like that
and in light of you know the the ukraine
russia
conflict that is happening recently you
know the news of myanmar and especially
there's a one specific article about our
sensitivity being you know in prison or
being charged for three years in prisons
we just made it to the news for around
three days before sliding back into
you know the uh the virtual archive of
the internet
which is something that i cannot really
understand because at the level of
brutality and violence is
you know
just beyond our understanding especially
in the context of the 21st century
so we decided to
this is the moment when we brought onto
this we bring all of this to the right
so
if you can talk a little bit about your
personal experience with this as well
so in the fall of 2021
uh i
participated in a
uh
a one credit course by cornell
university also the southeast asia
program from cornell and
uh i the course was called scholar
activism and the spring revolution in
myanmar and that
that in that course i and
a
friend from university of yangon was
like the only undergraduate students
there and
after the course i felt uh
like deeply inspired and then i
like for
a country like right in southeast asia
um
[Music]
and
uh like only two and a half
hours flight from from my home country a
hometown
uh
people are like
uh being killed being abducted and
uh being burned alive
um
uh and i i couldn't like
comprehend the the what what
the like i i feel very deeply for what
is happening there but i couldn't
comprehend like how such thing could
happen
uh
for
in in a place that's so near to me and
uh i right after the course i
uh
with fulbright historical society's help
i organized a webinar on humanitarian
crisis in southeast a uh in myanmar
and
after that
after
the webinar i felt like i need to do
something more not just
stopping at like a small webinar so i i
asked them about uh do you want to do a
project with me and we both feel very
strongly about what's happening in
myanmar so we got together and
uh after i communicated
that our project which started as like
two students from vietnam doing an
independent project with uh with with my
friend from uh yankon university and
she asked
if we wanted to collaborate and here we
are we have this project after like four
months of uh working
uh very closely together with the yangon
students
so in the next part of the presentation
we'll talk a little a little more deeply
about like the process of us like you
know like coordinating with uh people
that is very far away from us
based on merely the internet connections
which is another very interesting aspect
of studying the
collaborative kind of effort within this
project so you see on the screen right
now is the outline of our manuscript of
what we're having
right now in the zine and keep in mind a
lot of these content are in design but
some other you know future
informations and and concept will be
posted on on our uh website so please
stay tuned for that but for now we'll
talk a little bit about using and for
the interest of time we will just
breathe through several sections that we
think is
like that's what best highlight the
baby thea
what was interesting about diseases
so
so why is he uh why
so i don't think people would be very
familiar with this very specific type of
application but as a person who worked
in the arts for quite a while right now
zine is something that we as art labor
has been taking into consideration when
when we approach a topic that has
a relatively you know a different kind
of approach compared to other
traditional publication and now we are
taking
into account the urgency of the
other series of events that's happening
in myanmar and we also wanted to
to bring our own narrative into this and
to
to make it as flexible and at the same
time as creative and as critical as we
can so that we are not bound to any kind
of like standards or you know levitation
whatsoever so we decide to operate scene
which is a free flow and kind of like
non uh
regulated kind of
form of publication and and you will see
what what z
looks like in the next part
so uh
the first thing in our zine is uh i
think
you can talk about this very specific
interview and the process of our friend
costa
has gone through in order to and also
the story behind it
so uh
we
i worked closely with us costa a student
from yangon university and
to to produce the interview with the
idps
and
the interview with the students um
from uh uh the id the cdm students and
for uh the interview with the idps we
have one is the
um
story an act a small anecdote of a
volunteer
in in an idp camp in myanmar
and
she shared about
the her experience her christmas
celebration experience at um
at
the
idp camp which
was
majority christian
and
uh also at that in that day as uh we we
are updated were updated on
instagram about the burning of 35
uh
people
trying to on
while they are being on their way to
uh fleeing to an idp camp they were
caught by the
um
the tamar soldiers and they were burned
alive on the truck
uh
after hearing that news
and
i and
like after we just had a meeting the the
day before so that when she came to the
christmas celebration she can collect
the
costa can collect the
the story for hours in publication and
right before right after that the day
after
um
we had we received a new of 35 people
being burned to life and
uh we decided to like incorporate it
into
uh the
the story about christmas celebration
and
yeah we work very closely like we talk
almost like every day to get updated
with each other to share our uh to to
share the experience living
uh in
uh the in post called myanmar and living
in
um
uh
the states where
um
that where
um
[Music]
ethnic conflicts uh happen alongside
with uh the struggle for democracy
yeah
uh so for to produce the interviews uh
besides from like working very closely
with each other talking almost every day
we also have uh the ethical conduct
consultation with our
psychology professor from
fulbright university vietnam dr jill
school tip and because this is a
non-scholarly
publication
we
we
consult with
dr jill
for guidelines and ethical in interviews
uh to protect our interviews employees
and interviewers
solely uh like because we
uh because
um
we we are so afraid of like
hurting them anymore
uh from what they are experienced
already have already been experiencing
uh
by like
what we by by
the interviews that we want to do so um
the the interviews uh are not irb
approved or it is not um
not scholarly it is they are just uh
consulted and
uh follow and conducted following the
ethical conduct guidelines for
um
for for research but they are not uh
research material
so alongside with the interview with the
idp frontier that we just presented we
also have several other interviews
different
person
in different walks of life possessing
different professions
uh
and and how they all came together into
a very kind of
uh
kind of unified kind of like state of
being
in the context of postcode myanmar and
here uh like i
like i mentioned in in in the beginning
i had an interview with a burmese art
scholar which is finished her
uh
her degree uh in in in this state
uh and just literally just came back to
to to to myanmar and started
working like a part-time job alongside
with
like doing everything that she can to
raise fund and raise awareness about
what's happening in myanmar
so here in the interview by dinah zarwin
i tried to go very deeply into her
academic interests especially given that
her you know like background or in
burmese culture and environment history
in association with
uh you know like visual theories and and
art history in general so a lot of these
interesting perspectives will be covered
by diana
alongside would be her contemporary take
on
the uh
the cooked attack as well as the
revolution uh the the spring revolution
of 2021
and uh alongside with that we also have
other uh interviews with uh
an undergraduate student
uh at the university of yangon as well
as a haiku high school student which you
can also find in disease
and
i think another interview with a pdf
soldier
uh
where they will uh where he would talk
about
what diary looks like for a soldier who
is currently stationing in the jungle
and how and also this as you can see on
the screen those are the images of
uh the
the resistance soldier or training
uh where they are training and how
they're training
and you can find all of these details in
that insta in the pacific interview as
well
citizen is a kind of a a hot part of a
lot of different things that we think
that would best
uh
life in postcode myanmars will also
include a poems written
in the form of an arbitrary dedicated to
a foreign soldier
and we have a vermi version of it as
well as a
english translated version which was
translated by anjo who
unfortunately could not be here today
but also please have a look at that if
you're interested as well
and we also have commentaries because i
i myself
as an art student so i'm always
interested in how the relationship
between art and the social construction
especially at the time where
revolutionary spirit overheated in
myanmar and the brutality of the top
mothers keep resonating every day
it's very essential to see how art has
become
one of the essential instruments
to
look at
the entire spectacle
of myanmar as well as
it's a means of resistance
so you can you can find some of that in
in my essay where i discuss
two specific artists that i think best
gets event
uh
the idea that
the idea about art is a is a cyclical
system
and uh
this is a very interesting uh article
provided by funang so i think we can
talk about this one then this especially
connect with the
i think what eric has called by certain
asian youth solidarity so it's a funeral
can you talk a little bit about your
article
thank you
so i
uh because uh
most of the content in ours in
publication are they are quite heavy
in terms of like emotions and
content so i decided to
write something
still serious but um it is it has more
of a
humorous uh incoming uh
kind of vibe to it and we i wrote about
the
mimi biology of the spring revolution
and how the youth uh
um
use their that the young people is the
they're their
um
their their the nature their their uh
canon language of uh talking with uh
international communities international
youth uh using memes to to use those
into like
um doing revolution and as well as
raising awareness about what is
happening in their country
um
and also uh i think you um
to
[Music]
uh people can
uh go to our website and read alzene to
know more about uh how
about the commentaries
but i think uh it is time for us to
give the spotlight to the to the visual
rebellion teams
so
they can share a bit more about
their project as well as their
organization
thank you
thank you very interesting and we do
some similar things so it's interesting
so i'm i will introduce myself i'm laure
sigel i'm a french correspondent in
based in bangkok for eight years and
i was also
had the chance to be a a media teacher
in yangon me for the coup in 2019
[Music]
so i kept in touch with my students and
after the crew a few days bef after
um
some of them reached to me because they
simply did
the work they have been trained for so
they went in the streets in every
hometown they were so so as you know
kobe the
stopped most of studies of um and most
students had to go back to their
hometown so when the crew happened they
were
in their hometown
because study was was interrupted
already before
and so when it happened they
spontaneously went out to take pictures
to film
because they wanted to document this and
because some of them were already
working for the local media
so we have mostly people in
in ethnic states so rakhine and shan and
kareni
and maguez again
and one or two person in young guns so
the idea is that we would cover
places that were not
the main areas and where the information
was
very difficult to get so the best
way is to have local train young
journalists who have connection who know
the territory we know the local language
so it started i will
try to be quick it started
we called it the myanmar
photo project collective
can i share screen maybe
so i can just show you how it's
yeah
okay um
the myanmar project streettrove protest
so i told them
we work with 10 people at the beginning
in all these areas so every day they
would go out and they would send picture
information and together we would
the caption so we have all dates all all
context
or location and we translated every
slogan to right at the beginning
so the the beginning of the project so
this is sunday rakhine state the first
days and we did i will do it quick for
you but um
this is yangon
and
we did 15 episodes
of
archival picture from
street protests from everywhere
and we stopped i will show you the last
episode we stopped early may end of
march because as you might know march 27
on first day in myanmar it was extremely
violent the repression
and at this point it was just too
dangerous to go in the streets and also
in most places the big gathering stops
or we we
the last episode uh was um
a silent strike actually with just um as
you talk about creativity people found
ways
to express things uh in a different way
with no people uh to avoid danger of
arrest or worst
so this was against um a demonstration
against sexual harassment for women who
were arrested in jail and because there
was big
big scandal
in
april
um and then we had
the last picture from mandalay on the
monk and
it stopped
with the gear strike in uh so this was
already um a big repression in mandalay
and then on early may we got the last
picture from our journalist in in
someway
where it just went very
violent so you know it went for the
flash strike so 15 people went away and
even then even on this day people got
arrested
so it got very dangerous
so we we switch
um
to
first we
collaborate
with the ngo human rights in the picture
we base in the netherlands and for
decades they are helping filmmakers
in countries where you have a huge
political shock where people cannot walk
anymore
and then to
to help them save the footage to help
them do and do something with it edit
and give an audience to the to the
movies
so we did the photo part and
we created um
sorry
um
visual rebellion no
so this is um this is a
collaboration
between us
between our collective our
photojournalist and this organization
who help filmmaker on so the
naji uben who is the founder
she helped um
[Music]
pretty renowned filmmaker that we will
keep his name anonymous to
to make his documentary because for
months he filmed in uh in younger
insurance state in current state and
then he finally came to thailand and now
he's safe in another country but
we accompany him all the way so he can
finish his movie
and um
so this is the website
and so so the second thing we decide to
switch is that because we cannot send
people in the streets to cover street
protests anymore because it's so unsafe
um we switched to research so as you
know most most international
organizations cannot send the people
inside myanmar to get information on the
ground the think tank cannot work most
of the foreign staff have been pulled
out
and then you had all this
budget opportunities this need to know
what was happening
and we said we can fulfill this need
because we have trained local media and
workers across the country and we
started doing research so collaborating
with researcher republica which is a
think tank that was created 10 years ago
in
in myanmar
and they provide confidential reports
um
and then we publish with them
uh cyber a report about cyber security
in bosco myanmar
and then
it's it's long reports you can see i
will not open them it's 50 page each but
the idea was to teach
young journalists to work with young
researcher and then to get a
comprehensive
idea of the situation that were both
compelling in a tail in a journalistic
way but also with the academic context
so this one was about all the economic
difficulties in the country and how
people are copying how people are
resisting our last one published is
about the wall that is being built at
the moment between china and myanmar
and so we use we choose topics where we
have people but we will get out of
international interest of course so the
the next one will be about um
the pipeline and what's happening along
the pipeline from our time to
coming
and then we have one on the situation of
women in idp camps because of millions
of people one of this place by the war
and what's the situation for them
um
and we also do but this all of this is
we provide content but it's it's a
school it's to continue the pedagogical
the training that was um interrupted
because of copied of the crew because
this is this is experience they would
have learned by themselves but now it's
not possible so we continue this this
journalists in school we do by by
learning also they
they get a lot of time two three four
months to work on a long feature
um and at the same time we are doing a
lot of
of work on the side so we are we have
english lessons
online every evening
to give them opportunities to
[Music]
learn more
and
for the people who are to
to flee to thailand we help them
logistically we organize workshop here
and
so the idea is to provide all
opportunities they should have
to continue and to have a future as as
journalists as academics
at the same time that we provide very
localized
verified content
and what we want to do is actually to
have thai journalists and burmese
journalists working together because
most of them is people and when they can
flee
to thailand so you have lots of the
media now here
and we're still working with the sources
in myanmar but we need support a lot of
them have no identification paper so we
also help with
this getting scholarships for getting
and
getting to university getting some paper
and
this is why i have also invited in the
in the talk my two colleagues so we have
we have ko um with a thai journalist who
was
covering before for thai media myanmar
issues
and then we have we have nico who is
basically the co-founder of the
collective because he contacted me first
and he's the journalist from yangon
and
he's the author of the
is the author of
this report so we research
cyber security for four months um and we
published this
and he is also the author of short movie
so if you allow me i would like to show
you a short documentary
that was done
by him on this because we talk on on
signal and all his audio i get holy
stories by my audio now so this is one
this is his experience from the ground
so we do photo research video
while empowering people in them in their
professional life
so this is one movie and we have six
like this and then i will pass
a talk
um
[Applause]
bonus baseball
in tennessee
[Music]
i mean
i'm okay at least
i i was alive
at least i was alive
even i'm okay
i don't know how long we have had this
saturation
[Music]
is
and how long we have to
wait
to end this
sometimes i was
lost
my ambition
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
every day
i have no idea
[Music]
[Music]
i just go live on the morning alone
but
i'm not trying to stay strong
if i
can depress and just think about
okay i must stay alive
at least i was not dead am i not getting
mad
i'm
trying to motivate
my mind with that
okay so i will stop sharing my screen
and so it was not very organized as a
presentation but you can ask us
anything and um
and just to finish why we have
our ideas to have
ty and bernie's young journalists work
together because obviously they face
some of the same issues in their
generation and
and it's about politics but it's also
about the mekong river it's it's so many
things that people are sharing and to
learn about each other and the the
countries and the similarities in the
methods of the of the leaders and the
companies and
and there is so much people can learn
from each other so we also organize
workshops where people can share their
italian burmese journalists can share
the experience of covering protests of
relationship with state authorities of
of prison life of
of environmental struggle and how trying
to stay safe and how trying to
um to do work that will be seen because
we have also this problem that southeast
asia
has uh has gone a bit in a
in a whole of interest and we there was
some interest for some months at the
beginning
but then
it's
since since the war in ukraine it's very
difficult to get people interested in in
myanmar and this is also why we uh we
try to expand our
our articles we
we can explore our website we have
articles twice twice a month about what
we think is the main event
and actually um
five days after the invasion of ukraine
ukrainian people
protesting from the russian embassy in
bangkok and some thai people were there
and some burmese people were there so it
was pretty incredible to see this um
even not regional this solidarity and
people could see the same
enemy now in the in their eyes and make
connection with um
[Music]
with business and military power and
interest and so we write about this too
uh how how the situation in myanmar is
not is not
isolated and that it says a lot to
what's happening in the world and um and
of course myanmar was was such a hope
for for a lot of us
and uh and if we on our fall you have a
feeling that
um
it's it's about training for southeast
asia because they were showing something
else very imperfect that it was
something else there was something else
and
so we tried to explain that supporting
myanmar is supporting an id in asia but
also beyond that
so you can ask
any question you want to my to my
colleagues who are also on the ground
and of course to
to mikko we did an incredible work half
of the world collective so thank you i'm
sorry for the time yeah
thank you law um
so at this point we will have an open
discussion um
thank you so much for both of these
presentations um i i invite people to
raise their hand using the chat
feature or the reaction feature on zoom
and when the hand goes up i'll invite
you to ask the question and i'll keep
track of a queue
maybe i'll start off with the question
um
for fun and um
uh
maybe it's a a mildly sensitive question
and so you're you you don't have to
answer it completely if you don't want
to but um
you know
your your students at fulbright
university and you're working on um a
topic that raises certain questions
about
you know what's happening in myanmar um
the
i'm curious how you feel about the
sensitivity of raising these topics
within vietnam itself obviously you're
not talking about the politics of
vietnam in a particular way
but you are talking about another
country in asean right and vietnam
itself
has
certain obligations to asean but asean
has proven itself to be very um
unable to stand up and make any claims
right and so how do you navigate that
situation as young vietnamese students
who are seeing this tragedy
but also being mindful of
your own position
so i think i would like to take the
question and if we have anything to add
on feel free to chime in
but you're right eric that's exactly the
the first thing that we have to think
about when even before we start to have
any tangible outcomes of the project
because we're fully aware that
so apart from the thing that you said
about vietnam being attached to like the
non-intervention kind of like like
mandate
between south asian countries at the
same time when we talk about
events and information that concerns key
words such as rebellion revolution
and you know like
to you know like to to resist against
a certain sort of united government so
those are
some of the things that we will have to
communicate very very carefully
even though that our main goal is to
still
bring out the you know the rawest and
the most kind of a genuine kind of
perspective
within the scene so
so in the beginning we intended to to
make it like a physical
kind of publication so we would have a
hard copies to
to for people to to to get and hold in
their hands
and get them like if they're interested
in but a lot of that has been
kept like
left aside because of the communications
when it comes to print publications and
especially under the context of vietnam
those are
one of the things that are considered to
be taboo and you know like taking into
consideration the content itself
so eventually so we also intended to
have like a vietnamese version
and an international version where
everything will be in english
so
so we we also went through a lot of
like stages of consulting with different
people who have experience working in
independent publication we call
ourselves independent publication and
even though we're receiving help from
organization and you know affiliated
organization that we presented in the
beginning
but we're still a student-led kind of
project and we're
providing our own narrative based on the
materials that we collected
so a lot of that would not guarantee
us like a certain
neutrality or you know a certain
discourse where we
would not be touched by
you know like forces that like unwanted
forces
so eventually we decided to make this in
entirely english first of all to
like to make the narrative a little more
audible about the international
community and not
limited within the vietnamese community
and we're participating in in this
project as people
so we don't identify
we don't really identify with our own
national
you know like attribution but rather a
group of people who are
who want to
want to pay more attention into
the issue that's happening in myanmar
so that is like the very premise that we
really want to make clear so that when
readers approach our project they also
have a much clearer idea online
on right where we started and where we
are now
so set up my response i hope that
answered your question though
no thank you that was a wonderful answer
um paul sarno has a question
forget forgive me for uh some basic
basic question but uh is this how often
is the zine published how many issues
have you brought out
and um
is it i assume it's in paper or
give me the details please
uh so i can take this question oh
so
this is our first publication
uh we have been working on this own
seoul
publication since uh like the end of
october and
uh
but for future plans well
uh we we don't promise any
new publication or kind of establish
publication but we do have uh articles
blog posts and uh
events which we would very gladly be uh
collaborating with southeast asia do's
well let's
see
from you uh to
uh
to have like cross uh promotion as well
as like uh
uh like have our
articles
uh
uh co-writer or like have
uh collaborations on writing articles
and conducting uh interviews
or researches
if possible
um
the the focus of our collaborations
uh we we really want to focus to
collaborate with uh more youth
organizations and youth-led uh movements
uh from southeast asia
and from the international community to
raise awareness about uh the the
uh the the
the crisis in myanmar the humanitarian
crisis in myanmar we we want to focus on
young and independent youth-led and
people-led pro-democracy projects
uh
because we are also independent we are
also young and we and and often these
groups the people the youth are often
like the marginalized voices and we want
to like
if we go and we rise and we rest
together we want to like uh surface
their own
work as well as servicing their voices
their narratives about what is actually
happening in myanmar
um
for
for now we only know
that uh about visual rebellions uh not
know but like have connection with
visual rebellions and southeast asia
movement at yale but uh there are many
other
organizations as well as
people who
are
out
who are out there for example
there was a
youth-led podcast about myanmar
uh on instagram and i really want to
collaborate with that uh that podcast
but
i haven't reached out to them yet
thank you
thank you eric white do you have a
question
yeah i have a
um i guess a similar question
for both of the the
the participants one it it's basically
i'm kind of i'm just curious to know
more about
your interactions with your respective
peers and colleagues and what their
responses have been so for
tom and
you know like other
other students at the university other
students in vietnam i don't even know if
there's other students and association
groups in southeast asia and for laura
i'm just wondering about
more established kind of you know as a
photojournalist collective
what about more established photojournal
you know or journalistic media groups
and organizations or even advocacy
groups
uh ngos what not um
so yeah
so anything from from for for uh our
project from our place refund line uh
like i said in the beginning it isn't
it's like a very it's an extremely
independent kind of project that
involves
so like two of us like me and fun we are
the the
the main editors of disease so we're in
charge of you know
collecting the materials in very close
and discreet collaboration with
uh friends uh from uh
the interim university council
university of yangon so a lot of these
people helped
like venture out there into the
battlefields as well into the idp camp
to actually collect the incident all of
those would be entirely in burmese or uh
or like local dialectics
that would meet like another person from
the same team to actually translate them
so that we can
acquire the material entirely in english
or black language you know language
barrier is something that we also
consider
but there's this project but we're
fortunate to have friends
that are that are very passionate about
the project itself so we're capable of
according
coordinating with us during the
editorial process
so so everything happened in a very you
know like k by case kind of like basis
and sometimes internet connection would
not allow you know like
like continued kind of conversation to
go on so sometimes we'll have to take
breaks between
uh within the process so so eventually a
lot of the materials that we were not
able to get
uh
would be let out and perhaps in the
future they may reappear on
uh the category of blog posts on our
website
but uh
but again uh everything in the in our
project is very organic i think that's
the word the fact that we you know each
other both their friends and his
colleague
and and we just try to showcase in the
end what we have on like what we have in
our hands
i'll often jump to funerals is that
this
zine has an expiry date due to the
urgency
of of the matter that it wants to
communicate
so so with the opportunity from from uh
from uh yale at the the brownback series
as well
for future co-op collaborations we've
seen
we
want to to make this
appearance as prominent as possible so
that more people would get to read it
so like that's that's our main goals for
perhaps for the next two months and i
hope that answers your questions before
i pass it over to vlogger
and so
the first portfolio of pictures i show
you
so they were publishing media part but
we also publish long investigative
feature on media part and media part is
the leading investigative media in
france so it's in france but some of it
was translated in english so that was
our main um
collaboration for media and then um
for the research part our research was
financed by the united states institute
of peace which are the big uzip which
are the big presence in myanmar
for the crew
so they
they gave us the budget to do what they
couldn't anymore because the staff
couldn't walk anymore so we it was
financed by uzip and
and supported also by article 30 which
is a pronoun
think tank about business and human
rights it was funded by matthew mellen
who was term teacher in a bangkok
university and who is now back in the us
and then we have collaboration with
research centers or journalistic centers
in bangkok for the moment so we
we have free photo exhibition now
uh so our photo edition was shown at the
foreign correspondent club in thailand
at sea junction which is this research
center about southeast asia
and then we have one at the moment in
the hague
in the city hall in the netherlands in
the heart because we want to reach
other countries
so
so this
our collaboration and we also at the
moment have a partnership with um
in term of photo especially so sopa
image it's a big photo agency that has
been created recently in asia
so we will open an account and they have
they have
access to get the image now so our our
picture our best selection of picture
would be available on super image so
we're also trying to teach about
integrating a news photo agency how to
select your picture how to so we work
for super image and then saka photo
which is a collective also who helps
photojournalist in myanmar since the
crew
we collaborate they help us
getting access to safety training
that we then give to our team
so everything about cyber security
safety training
mentorship
so we work with establish photo
collective to get their
advice and to to help each other yeah uh
but for sure if the picture on that
image that would be much easier enough
to disseminate in international media
and we have um
we we walk also with with heart stories
that i want to
say a word about because it's a
colleague who was
helping us from the very beginning from
this project and he founded this
media two years ago now and two years
ago
about human rights defender in thailand
so every future stories every people who
fight for
for gender rights for environmental
rights for political rights
we love the story feature on this media
there is no advertisement
it's
good quality
picture and feature
and basically what he does for thailand
we try to do with myanmar and the idea
is to have a original feature
investigative media at the end so we
start with thailand and myanmar yeah
that's the idea
um yeah
thank you um i i also want to uh add in
that
is uh
uh we really
uh for our
interaction with colleagues and
uh teammates we really uh because we are
also
very young and we are also only
undergraduates and we just first start
with uh doing
this kind of works um
i really we really look up to uh
our collaborations and as well as uh
cons
as interaction
uh with um more established uh
organizations like visual rebellion and
what as well as like uh other
uh as our peers from pogba to
um
learn more about how to do better
interviews or
have uh more
uh dynamic uh to to surface and
highlight more dynamic perspectives of
of the cool of the people's life
and
uh
we really have a
big ambitions to like produce good
content
especially
uh project uh providing uh insights into
what this what life is like for uh
post in post school myanmar
and we actually wanted to to add a page
we're discussing this this week at the
page on
our website to promote the work of other
groups um because i think it's really
important to
um yeah some solidarity nobody's doing
this for profit and it's like helping
each other to
to get our own work and to collaborate
um
for example we do this for photo
exhibition also we collaborate um with
um
a burma woman organization from an
organization of myanmar so they provided
half of the picture from women in the
streets and we provided half of it and
and then we we make collaboration with
civil society groups inside myanmar too
and i think it's really important to
show the work of of other people um
and to promote it yeah
and we also try to um
you is so you your colleague was
mentioning this about the burmese
version of course it's really important
so now uh mikko is with us no no he's is
the one who is
[Music]
responsible for the burmese version so
now we started he's finally in in safety
with us so he can work and um
he provides the burmese version for our
social media channel and he disseminates
our post into burmese facebook groups
that i will never have idea about no so
he knows all this
generation said the geek
anime facebook group
which has three million people and you
never earn 1.3 million thing and it's
like
so um
our work was much more shared since we
have the social media posts of course
were shared in the white place
um
and we are waiting for our next gwent to
be able to translate our website in
burmese the whole website so that's the
idea yeah
to reach also
i just want to interrupt because we have
a question from
who has been active with penn myanmar
with one of the founders of penn myanmar
and also as a leader of penn
international now and i think can speak
to some of these kinds of connections so
matidah you have a question go ahead
uh
not much question i just want to
appreciate you know i really really feel
so
grateful to the walk of these two
projects and i think
uh on the ground the
highest
violent uh area is right now is the kind
division and the greater vision
hopefully
we can raise more awareness about the
burning of the whole villages and
arresting and the killing people there
and then
raising fundings for them too not just
for the other area because the
most violent areas are these areas and
then
another issue is i might say
for the
uh
writers and the some other
people it's really have no platform to
uh
to keep their livelihood indeed even
though they can make they can create but
they cannot make earning out of it and
they have so much uh
problems facing
till now so this is a big big challenge
for them to keep going on so this kind
of the platform will be
a little bit helpful for them if they
can be reached out or if they can reach
out to you something like that so i i
will uh try
my best to help
reaching out to them and reaching back
to you something like that that's what i
can also do but uh it's still very hard
for them to keep their livelihood under
their rear pen name something like that
it's still very much
challenging you know even though we are
safe
right now what they do is they revoke
the citizenship so i can
also be revoked my citizenship and then
they also seized the
assets and raided their homes and
yeah they confiscated the homes and the
publishing houses that's kind of the
atrocities is going on that's why the
situation
uh this kind of situation i i do hope to
be shared and
also
the arbitrary arrest is not just limited
to the adult but also to the
kindergarten kids you know if they
cannot arrest the the parents they
simply arrest three years old
yeah kids something like that so this
kind of very uh
big atrocities will be uh
published i i do hope yeah thank you
thank you so much
thank you mata i think that raises a
really important point
about the ways in which our acts of
solidarity also have to think very
strategically
about how we can care for people on the
ground whose risks are so much greater
than
you know even though we may put some
labor into something
the risks on the ground and very basic
questions of livelihood
and how we can come up with technologies
to transfer some of those necessities
at the same time as making the the the
knowledge available to the world right
there's multiple issues that are
happening at the same time so thank you
for raising that matida um lisa bruton i
think this will be our last question um
and then uh we
when we're finished with the q a we can
also hang out a little bit in an
informal session but this will be our
last formal question hi lisa thank you
hi hi thank you so much everybody great
and such interesting projects um
thanks for sharing them
part of my question was already answered
i think by uh
laura is it um
from visual rebellion i wanted to ask
about uh how you're supported
and i'm assuming that from our place to
the front line is supported by your
university in fulbright
um and that kind of leads me to the
question of
how you kind of perceive of these
projects kind of in the longer run are
these sort of
are you sort of thinking about these as
eventually sort of archival projects are
you thinking about them
like
as a sustainable ongoing kind of thing
i'm just wondering if there are any
ideas about
further networking especially from the
from our place to the front line
folks i mean
we see the wonderful like expansion of
the milk tea alliance
among you know many more regional
countries and i'm wondering if there's a
chance to maybe do that with your if
that's something you're thinking about
so kind of what where are you thinking
about these projects as you go forward
um and and especially for yeah i mean
for both for both of you
so maybe visual rebellion can go first
and
uh we can go after again
um
so the
the grant we received at the beginning
when um
production basis now you get some budget
to produce a specific thing and now we
are trying to we apply um now to apply
for grant for functioning costs to be
able to function for a year
um to to have some some income for our
team and to have some emergency funds to
have the budget for the english lesson
so we are aiming for
administrative functioning
costs that we ask in the gwents
the our first year of operation was like
showing what we can do and now we we
would like to to be able to finance some
appropriate room
um i also wanted to add that everyone
has always been fed um
what they produced for us the reserve
for the research for the picture for and
i try to apply the same weights that
international media are applying now
so you get what i should get and
and you produce something
but for me the long term as i said
visual rebellion is is what you create
after after a shock
but my long-term idea is
is to provide the opportunities and the
skills and the resources
for the team to be able to stand by
themselves
as freelance journalists to make a
career like we do
and then they
for example i'm supporting them to
entering university to pursue the
studies or
or we we support them to apply for jobs
in in
international or burmese media while
okay we're looking for contributor
so i i would consider that my work is
done when everyone of
a student is
relatively safe as a as an income and as
a job and as collaboration and do the
career that he should have done um
so it's it's
it's a content project but for me it's
also a pedagogical project and it's not
out of of course i have a lot of
affection for them they're my students
but it's not out of of charity it's like
this region needs to train young
investigative journalists um
to to to
to move forward politically too and in a
social level and and my job is being a
journalist being this so this is where i
can contribute
and i truly believe that if
[Music]
people are giving
the technical intellectual critical
skills
to provide the information that the
people need
it's it's we contribute somehow to
a change in society and as we know that
this information is such a problem in
myanmar i mean there was a lot of
pointing down that myanmar is something
that we see in every country but the the
myanmar case has been researched a lot
because it was intense and it was
focused on facebook and it was focused
on this very
uh horrible event
i mean the rohingya community and there
was all this thing it it
it represents
there is a big problem no there was a
big problem and how do you move beyond
this um
beyond the pointing down at burmese
people because this is not the solution
and it's like how do you
what's the problem what's the root
problem of this information on
nationalism and all of this and
for me it's putting people together and
thai
regional journalists talk to each other
see there is common issues and how we
work together because you also
in in the school system there is also a
lot of misconceptions about all the
neighboring countries so
and people don't know are not taught
much about other countries and the
regional situation and it's
and the military alliance has said lisa
is was something really important and
hong kong and myanmar so are really
important and needs to be supported and
our way is to
teach
investigative reporting to teach how to
deal with international media with
international clients
simply so you can have the the chance to
have a career like like all of us here
this despite the terrible situation in
the country
um
so yeah in short we try to get gwen for
annual
um
functioning and then um
i i as i said i would consider that my
job is done when all of them as a um
as a stable situation yeah and can do
the work they they should
but visual rebellion will always be open
it works on a volunteer basis
for the people who contribute their
payment for the people behind who help
on the website
um it's volunteer and it's photo editor
video editor
journalist
because we we believe that you need to
to to share you your knowledge at a
critical time like this because if we
don't really don't do it now um
there is not a better time than now that
changed the media landscape in myanmar
and we work with a small group of people
but it has repercussions because they
work themselves in local media in
myanmar so what they learn we will have
a percussion in the whole community
local community of journalists
um
yeah so thank you can i hear from the
front line to place it
yeah from the other group thanks
thank you so much uh so
maybe i will talk first and then uh if i
miss anything uh you can follow up and
so
we
about the funding and
uh the affiliation with uh fulbright uh
we currently uh so the
for the zen publication
until now
uh we haven't had any funding or we have
and um like we we didn't have
need to like
spend any
money on the project
but
now you you're mentioning about the
funding as well as
um
how to keep the project financially
alive um i
we we haven't talked talked about that
we we just think about like how to
surface and how to bring people's voices
uh to
to to the international community and
especially the
southeast asian youth the southeast
asian uh region
um
and
uh
as uh laura was speaking uh i about the
the unpaidness of the the journalists as
well as uh the
the people who work in uh
media in myanmar uh i also know about
the case of um
uh
uh
civilian reporters also raising funds
like by themselves on social media in
platforms namely instagram to fund for
their own traveling like uh for example
if they join the people
people's defense force they need to like
have their own skype and
no one is going to provide them that and
they
rise by themselves so maybe
um uh
we we we're just just a group of
students but just
it's just something that pop out of my
head when i think about it so maybe
in the future some organizations
um
can can
like try to like have a more established
way of
uh helping these uh civilian reporters
as well as indeed independ independent
journalists to
um
get paid for what they're doing
in order to sustain the the
the flow of um
news
into about uh myanmar
and
um
but there's also
um
thank you to eric uh
so there is also um
another thing that i want to rise is
which i i haven't seen anywhere where
people discuss this is the gray zone of
the
um the the
the revolution
uh
they are so we we have already always
see the revolution as something very
binary between the military and the
people and which the military in the cdm
but there are like
uh also
soldiers defect
defectors from the military trying to
join the cdn
uh
they
as we we you all may have known
uh
the the the talmud the
military munta has a very
separate uh system
uh
uh in in alongside the civilian uh
government system in myanmar that's why
they sustained until the present day and
they are p there are defectors soldier
defectors um
from calling for help from uh
myanmar who who want to defect the
military wanda but they have family and
they have other strings attached to
them that the template that they
uh haven't been able to and they have
not received as much
uh
help from the international community as
the cdm
uh
p as the cdm and
and
[Music]
and and the civilians uh when it comes
to uh doing the revolution
uh
i i i personally consider them as like
the gray zone of the revolution
yeah
uh
them do you want to follow up
so uh circling back to to list the
questions about what our next step will
be like would be like uh given that we
are so for
so for this specific project we as soon
as mentioned we did not receive any
funding from any institution whatsoever
and everything was done based on
our like
daily interactions with uh the students
and and and friends from from yangon
university and
and due to the overwhelming kind of
urgency of the of the zip publication we
solely focused on that very
that that one specific thing to work
towers and now
uh and now we just started thinking
about you know like what the next step
for us would look like but before the
next two months i think we'll try our
best to get into events like these so
again thank you
eric and and braddock's routine for
creating this opportunity for
for us to to talk about our project
so so so yeah update yourself for i
think more future updates about how we
are going to reimagine the project
itself
but again for the next two months i
think we're focusing we'll be focusing
on promoting disease to
the international community
thank you everyone for this fantastic
conversation we're at the end of our
time i'm going to stop recording but
first i want to record us uh giving a
round of applause to to the speakers in
the in the group thanks lord tom and
funyun this is really exciting